hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
last month i spent a week of my life
helping one of my employees become
financially free she became financially
free in five days from scratch it was
absolutely incredible and this is a
month later to talk about exactly what
happened since our her property is still
going well so amelia welcome to winners
wednesday thank you thank you for having
me so you have been heading up winners
on a wednesday for almost two years now
where you've been
inviting guests who are financially free
as a result of the training onto the
show and now you are on the other side
as a financially free student how does
it feel it feels really strange to be
fair like now i understand the pressure
that they feel really how do you what do
you mean because i feel like quite often
when i'd ring winners they'd always be
like oh i don't know whether i'm ready
and to be fair we had that conversation
i was like oh do you really think i
should come on just yet yeah so um i
kind of understand their their position
now okay so um
tiny bit of backstory how did we meet
how did this start and then we're
literally in this interview i want to
break down what we did behind the scenes
answer questions that people had some of
the things that people are confused
about and i really just want to inspire
people and let people know that i mean
they've been people even since the
documentary the film came out that have
literally gone and started doing deals
just from watching our movie it's blown
up it's currently on 32 000 views all
organic which is crazy so how did this
all start and how did this come to
happen yeah so i first met you when it
came down to a crash course so my mum
has kind of always done little bits of
property but she's never kind of gone
and got training for it so i came across
you online and i was like oh this would
be really good for my mum to go to and
i'd be interested as well so we came
down i think it was 2018 like november
time um and we came down to the crash
course and obviously i absolutely loved
it um but we didn't really have much
money at the time so my mum actually
paid for the dfe on credit cards
um
and she wanted me to go instead of her
because she was like you know you'll
remember the information you can relate
back to me
and so
that basically happened but she was like
you know you need to get a deal to pay
me back for this you know it's alone um
i was in my third year of university so
i was quite busy um and i actually saw
that you had a competition that
christmas when your first financial
freedom challenge came out
and you said you know whoever does the
best description and i'll put that as
the description to the video you can get
some free training so i was like oh
amazing because i haven't got time right
now to go and secure some property deals
to pay my mom back so i actually won
that competition in the end i think i
was like spamming you on like a
christmas day like yeah caption and um
yeah and then i got it was able to then
pay my mom back because i got the the
free training and so that's kind of how
we
first came about that's awesome and it's
so funny how everything's come full
circle because now you're in charge of
running those types of giveaways you're
like right let's do a giveaway and
people are commenting and then it's like
well you you were one of the people that
were commenting on the giveaway yeah
okay so you invested onto the deal
finding extravaganza um but you ended up
also getting money towards it from the
from the uh the voucher from the
giveaway which is awesome yeah um so you
came on the training and how old were
you at the time oh how old was i in
third year you know i couldn't even
remember would have been like 21. about
21. so you're you're at university yeah
you're 21 you don't have any money
you've managed to somehow haggle your
way onto the deal finding extravaganza
with your mom's
um your mom got a credit card
slash giveaway you're at the deal
finance tougher gams there um which is
which is obviously great and and at this
point where are you at like what what
happened next yeah so i i was really
confident about you know doing property
i've always had a bit of a
entrepreneurial kind of spirit and and
my head was a you know i might set up a
business after university um and then
with that money that i made from that
business i'll put it into property and
then when i kind of went to the crash
course i was like why wouldn't i just go
straight to doing you know straight into
probably want to skip the job part yeah
why why would i do that but you know i
didn't love like the startup kind of
lifestyle you know i'd worked for a
startup over in australia and i was
really into that world so i was actually
meant to work for a startup in leeds
when i when i finished what was what was
the startup the startup it was kind of
like an app for for students
um and i added you know one um you know
business plan competitions and all sorts
of in my third year so you were
hungry yes i was hungry you know what i
saw about you i started to cut you but i
remember
around this time when you were just
starting to do a bit of training you're
just finishing uni i know i saw a post
where you were like i'm looking to know
what to do should i go full time into
property should i get a job what should
and i remember saying to you
if you want a job as a videographer
because i'd seen you had a little
youtube channel you've done a couple
videos i'm like okay you know she's kind
of got a i saw you know something about
you and i remember saying to you look if
you want a job as a videographer then
we need a videographer right now what
how did that conversation go yeah so you
actually put a so i'd kind of seen you
you know making moves doing really well
and you know all the training side of it
and the property side and i was really
inspired um and i saw so it was one day
the the startup that i was meant to work
for it fell through because they didn't
get funding and also a flat that was
meant to go on shared ownership which
now i know isn't isn't a good thing are
you about to get shared
oh you'd have been in the death trap
you'd have been in a job where you were
working nine to five shared ownership
death trap till 67 yeah yeah literally
so so that company wanted me to to work
for free for their startup and i was
like what if i was going to work free
i'd work for my own business so that
kind of fell through that was in the
week my dissertation was due so it was
very stressful after university i went
back to my village and i was just kind
of sat there and i was like is this is
this life like i've gone to university
i've got a first class degree i've done
super well and now i'm sat back in the
village that i was in before right and i
haven't got a job right so i was on
facebook and i was you know as you do or
you don't have a job i was you're
absolutely yeah i was really upset i
didn't know what i was gonna do and you
know i thought i had these plans and
they both fell through like the the flat
and the uh working for the startup and
then i saw a post by you and you said um
i'm looking for a videographer in london
um you know comment down below if that's
you and my mentality was so bad at the
time that i just thought i'm not in
london so that can't be me and i think i
just posted something like you know i
haven't got a job at the minute you know
if you're ever up in manchester i can
you know work for free i'm a loser
with a degree first honors but
right yeah so you offered to work for
free from my company but you didn't want
to work for free from the startup why is
that um because i saw more
of valuing like i understood the you
know the networking element of it and
also i just really aligned myself with
everything that you were doing so i was
happy to you know if you were at a
manchester and was struggling for a
videographer i was very happy you know
i'm not doing anything else in my time
so um so yeah i i commented on that post
and you instantly messaged me directly
on instagram on facebook and i was
thinking
what and you kept asking me questions i
think you said something like are you
good
[Laughter]
are you
good
as in
are you good at videography yeah what a
question are you good yeah and i was
just like yeah i am like i can do this
yeah so i remember sending you a video
and saying can you do something like
this yeah could you shoot something like
this and you were like easy
yeah literally so i um you then rang me
and i think we're on the phone for about
28 minutes and
i'd basically agreed to move down to
wolverhampton
with the company while while you were
moving down to london and then straight
down to london and this was i think the
thursday night or the friday night did i
like use my nlp on you or something like
a hypnotizer
so you agreed to move from manchester to
wolverhampton knowing that three weeks
late you'd have to move from
wolverhampton to london start within a
couple of days yeah that weekend i was
um
like taking pictures from my cousin's
wedding so it wasn't even like i was
free and you wanted me to start on the
monday and meet you with doncaster so i
was literally like i've got so much to
saw i've got social media but i was like
this is such an amazing opportunity so
yeah i came down and met you amanda and
another video through that a
videographer that then shadowed um in
doncaster on that monday and that's
that's basically questions started
obviously we've got quite a lot of
members of staff i think we've got about
31 people right now on the payroll um
you have done the financial freedom
challenge i've helped you in property
why you over other people what do the
other 30 members of staff think about me
spending a week with you
what's the situation there how is it
fair
yeah so i think um
because i've kind of invested in the
train and i think a lot of time as staff
obviously you
you do get to go to the events you do
kind of obviously hear things and you're
in conversations and you kind of get
training without even you know paying
for it
but not limited yeah but limited right
so then i was well what do i say to you
when you asked me property questions
before you joined the academy
so you said to me i used to like be in
the car with you and i'd be like samuel
you know what um you know what mortgage
would you get this and you'd be like
okay okay so there's this guy on youtube
and i think it's around on sunday at 7
p.m you can maybe ask him a question
yeah
this is this thing i'd say put this in
your diary 7 p.m on sunday there's a q a
going on on youtube right obviously it's
an argument but in other words like you
know listen listen you're doing a job
you can't be asking me questions people
pay good money to get trained
like that's not that's not how we roll
and i can remember when we're at the um
when i started because i came down to
london and i didn't you know it all
happened so fast i didn't understand how
expensive london was or how i was really
going to navigate i hadn't even sorted
you know a flat out i was sleeping on
people's sofas and floors for weeks and
um
i i remember talking to you because i
was like i need to deal source deal
source will be a way for me to get more
money so then i can have a better
lifestyle in london
so i think i remember we have had a one
comment conversation one time we were in
the car and i think i just asked you one
too many questions and you were like
listen
you know you're in a career now you know
you need to like focus on that or you
know choose property and go off and kind
of do that
and at that time initially i was a bit
like oh you know taken back by it i
understood what you meant but i was like
you know what what should i do um and i
chose to focus on my career
um and it you know it definitely paid
off you know within the first like six
months of the company i was uh promoted
twice
um which obviously was was amazing and
was everything i wanted you know i'm i
am very much even though i'm
entrepreneurial i am very much an
entrepreneur and i like being in
companies that are growing and doing
really well
um so
that was that was incredible but then it
came to like two years later um you know
around you know a few months ago and i
still had that itch to do property
because i'm the one you know sorting
winners out in here and they're amazing
like incredible stories
i always thought like you know i do want
to get into property you know i'll put
it off for a few years but it got to the
point where i was like i do really want
to do this even if it's just you know a
few properties and just learning and the
best way to learn is
do the training and then you know take
action
so i then joined the academy
um because i realized that to have
people take me seriously and you to take
me seriously i need to you know pay for
the training and for sure that and
that's smart i was a small i bet you're
glad you did yeah oh yeah
and again for you it must have been
tough joining the academy because
a lot of the training you'd been filming
you'd actually edited some of the online
courses for the academy members so you
you know may have felt i don't know
maybe you didn't but when i said to you
look
if you want to really do this yourself
if you want to be treated seriously if
you want people to invest in you if you
want
you need to invest in yourself right you
need to get the training you need to get
yourself in the right environment and
there's a difference between being a um
in an environment when you're a delegate
when you're an investor and when you're
a videographer you need to join the
academy and
and then fine i'll support you
but still
you're gonna have to do this on your
holiday time
in your evenings and weekend so when did
that all happen when did we start having
those that conversation of like are you
gonna do this what what's what yeah so
it was a couple of months ago now um and
i basically said you know i'm gonna take
this serious and i'm gonna book a week
off work um and you know if you wanted
to to come around with you with your
film crew and help
that would be amazing so i would kept
being like oh you know it would be great
if you know we can do a financial
freedom challenge what about this and
this like we can picture it's like you
know employee and boss and and you were
kind of like okay yeah yeah yeah that
sounds good and it was only until i
think it was only until i i took it
seriously and obviously paid for the
academy and was like i'm doing this
that i saw you're a bit more like warmed
up to it
and then i remember when we were
announcing the millionaires challenge
from the eviction um obviously i'd like
organized all the eviction and and
done all that kind of side of it and i
was actually there filming for that for
the millionaires uh reveal and you know
i saw evans proposing to ellen and it
was just such like a magical day and i
was just there you know starting to pack
up the the camera and thinking you know
you were done now for the day and you
invited me up on stage
and i was thinking oh what i thought you
were just going to say you know thank
you for helping and and that kind of
thing like i do always yeah are you just
like come on stage and then
you basically just announced that you're
going to do a financial freedom
challenge with me and i i was honestly
taken back because you know i'd
obviously asked and i didn't think you
actually would and because i knew how
busy you were going back to the events
after lockdown and stuff and so i just
felt like super grateful um and i just i
felt a little bit anxious like i was
excited but i knew that okay like it's
crunch time like it's game time like
this is actually it's an important week
now oh massively so um yeah and then i i
did all the online trading and
absolutely loved it and um yeah it's
just crazy because now it's like see
knowing that everyone's seen a video of
me where it's like because i basically
didn't really do anything in terms of
taking action until the challenge
because i wanted it to be you know a
beginner and starting and so people can
relate to me you did the training yeah
because i feel like as well i wanted
people to be able to relate to me
because you know i'm a regular girl from
a regular background you know i did uni
and then i was in a job and you know i
was probably getting the sort of income
that you know you would do at my age if
you know you're doing quite well but
it's nothing you know to write home
about nothing like incredible so i
thought you know it's going to be
amazing for people to see a regular girl
you know taking the train and then and
then for the first time putting it into
action um you know i could have
done loads of practice before the day
you know so i didn't look like a silly
on camera but i just thought
i'm going to be vulnerable i'm going to
put myself out there and hopefully it'll
help someone and even the way you like
walked into some of the estate agents
and we're just like hey i'm looking to
the rent to rent like yeah you know we
had a blast that week and look through
the week i'm sure everyone's watched it
but if they haven't you did
a deal a day for five days you did a
lease option agreement serviced
accommodation rent to rent in clapham
the windsor deal
house hacking deal uh you bought a
freaking house
the the that you're gonna um
live in so it was crazy you packaged and
sold a deal you basically
smashed it smashed it smashed it out the
park and the deals that we did did you
find them the
prior or did were they all like from
scratch that week like what was the
actual setup behind the scenes yeah so
the deal that we sold and i actually in
the challenge we didn't know whether you
know when we put the video out i didn't
know whether it was 100 going to go
through because it was very back and
forth with the landlord but i'm happy to
now announce that the deal has gone
through four grand yeah four grand bank
and and you know what the question asked
you though was the deals that we did so
for instance that deal that you sold
yeah
i wanted to intentionally do everything
start to finish and do it as a movie so
people could see how to do it so the
deals that we found
like what i'm asking is how from scratch
was it i know i pulled my contacts in to
help out yeah but the actual deals when
did you find them how did you find oh
yeah it was all it was all from scratch
like the week before i was a little bit
nervous and i was you know i started to
i didn't really know what i was doing i
just started looking like for brr deals
and and nothing came off like nothing
was anything that we then used in the
challenge like in the challenge
everything was just from from scratch i
think the thing is with this market you
can't plan a financial freedom challenge
because if you find a property two weeks
prior and line it up yeah by the time it
comes it's gonna have gone yeah and you
were saying to me the week before is
there anything i should be like doing or
should i be like and i was just like
just chill just make sure that you're
well rested and during that week we can
we can go to town and smash it so okay
so of the deals then did any of them
fall through um
no they've all gone ahead yeah well
obviously i was like i was just saying
the deal that um i saw i did think you
know the landlord was taking so long so
much negotiation i was thinking
potentially that could not go through so
you've not given the keys back to any of
the properties no
so that's where he's in yeah do you know
what that actually is amazing because
normally in business i even said to you
on the week i'm like look some of these
deals may fall through yeah that would
be okay yeah so um with the properties
then talk to me about how you managed to
rent them out how you managed to get
them out so fast talk me through the
process of what what happened the monday
after so we spent the week together and
then and then i'm like right
you know we're done congratulations we
go out clubbing and everything's great
and you're financially free what then
happened what happened the week after
yes so that it was a bit you know i got
back into my uh flat and i was just kind
of sat there like this has been the
craziest week of my life um
i had so much to sort like even in terms
of the property that i'm buying you know
sending over all the documents and there
was a lot of of um sorting things out
and even with the landlords in terms of
the rent to rents the two rental rents
that i got it was almost like i had to
seal them again after the challenge
yeah because they realized that because
obviously we we did it together and they
were like okay you know samuel
but then when i went and i was like oh
it's a santy estates that you're going
to be signing the contract with they
were like okay and you've this is the
first time you're doing this in this
company so i did have we did have that
though in the week we had that awkward
conversation with matt yeah
but but but i know what you mean about
how there's a lot of aftermath did the
penny drop to the landlord that oh
samuel's not here anymore yeah a little
bit so i had to kind of
basically negotiate and sell myself and
you know with some of the deals i am
put like get gave her like upfront rent
and to basically be like you know i'm
serious i'm gonna you know
i'm in and i'm gonna do this but i
actually put that whole conversation on
youtube because i felt like it was
important and it was it didn't fit in
the documentary but i thought it's such
an important i put the entirety of the
conversation which was you and it was
during the week it was you speaking to
matt the landlord from clapham having to
drop the news that by the way i've
actually got a new company that was set
up two weeks ago i got no money i got no
assets i got no references i got no
guarantors
because we'd sold matt and we kind of
did a little bit
use my
cred
matt didn't know me but the way that we
spoke and i was like oh yeah we've done
this before kind of thing which is true
but then when the
coffee hits home and it's like actually
mrs amelia and this is the same with
academy members people come to the
academy they're in the environment
they're hitting the phones there are
they're next to me they're next to all
these people but then it's like actually
after the training program finishes
they're on their own of course they've
got the support they can pick up the
phone that we can still work with with
people but it's like
what was that like so so so what
happened did you have any comeback did
you have any landlords say i don't like
this i'm not comfortable um what did you
do
yes so i actually i went to meet the
landlords again face to face so um we
actually hadn't met matt face to face so
i went and met him um and you know
talked over everything and it's so funny
because both landlords are the opposite
like matt is very much like pay me i
don't want to hear from you and then my
other landlord is like
he lives down the road and i could go in
and fix stuff and so it's it's great to
have that difference in them and kind of
learn how to deal with i guess different
landlords and i've you know formed great
relationships with both of them amazing
amazing so um what else have you done i
mean there's the deals on the week which
we we completed and we got them done but
then as you say there's still a bit of
back and forth with the landlord and the
teething problems which you sorted out
what other deals have you done yeah so
um just to go back as i do want to say
um the deal that i sold to jl we
actually got that from um
deal sources yeah on on the academy
which is amazing because i think that
probably didn't come through as much in
the documentary um but i basically got
paid two grand for basically just
bringing people together i found a deal
from someone and we went and saw it and
checked it was all good and then we
found jl and i negotiated to to
basically make that deal so you were
just the ultimate middleman yeah got
paid two grand totally got paid two
rounds to do yes that's epic yeah that's
epic and shout out to everybody you know
blaze and spence yeah
uh even clement that didn't do business
with us but what a fabulous chap of
years all the all the people that you
know the landlords matt and and and the
windsor landlord i can't remember his
name
evans oh it was so good seeing evans
come back in his fancy car
and and like be
in a position of money and yeah he's now
the investor he was the person that was
begging for money now he's the investor
yeah you'll probably be in a year or two
years time but uh oh i'll invest in your
deals yeah it was so interesting seeing
the growth and even one thing i forgot
to say is um i filmed so obviously we
had the eviction and then we had david
lawton and evans who you then did
financial freedoms challenges with this
time last year um and
it was actually lawton's ff challenge
that i filmed in the january and he i
remember sitting there and thinking like
he
was in a worse place than me he was you
know in debt and all these things and by
the end of the week like i think he'd
made was it like eleven thousand pounds
yeah and he got plans and he had all
these deals and i was thinking i'm in a
better position
than he is so i was just thinking you
know if he can do this in a week
what could you know what what potential
could i kind of and do you know create
for myself so it was actually i think at
the end of that challenge you can
actually hear i edited it in because i
was like maybe samuel will do it then
but at the end of that challenge i
actually said to you will you do a
financial challenge with me and you like
laughed it off but i was thinking i'm
like join the academy and then let's
have a conversation and i'm manifesting
it
but the thing is as well it's
all
take people seriously to take yourself
seriously i always say you make one move
i'll make one move and sometimes people
message me oh can you do this can i have
a coffee with you can i can you do a
[ __ ] can you move to my house i'm like
you don't even come to my free training
yeah you don't even show up because you
can't be bothered to do a one-hour
commute but you want me to come to your
house yeah uh come on let's get real you
know what i'm saying yeah 100 well i you
know i've even looked on our social
media and we the amount of messages that
we have about financial freedom
challenges and people like come but it's
the first message they've ever sent you
they've never even purchased a book or
and it's just it is kind of is crazy and
i think you know that's one thing that
maybe people wouldn't see through the
challenge is they might think oh you
know maybe she just got handed to her
and but they haven't seen the nearly
three years worth of work and going to
events and like
all the work and you and your mom
between the two of you you're on the
academy your mom's on the academy um you
you did the dfc obviously that was for
years ago now how much of you and your
mom invested between the two year into
training through our company yeah a lot
so i think it's now like 22 000 right
and she's now on the development the
development academy as well so but the
thing but the thing is this though it's
like it's like when you invest in
yourself now you're in a situation
whereby you're financially free what
does it feel like to be a situation now
where you have the status of financial
freedom what does that feel like
it's
insane like i think until the
documentary came out i hadn't really
thought about it because there was so
much i needed to do like sorting
everything out setting them up and also
editing the the financial freedom
challenge and so there was a lot you
pretty much edited that yeah which is
which is funny yeah so it was weird kind
of watching myself back and when it went
out
it was just mental for me because i
hadn't sat back and thought okay i'm
financially free now so when everyone
was like messaging me like well done and
oh my god it's incredible
it kind of just set in yeah and it feels
amazing like it does feel like
incredible to know that you've got that
there because i think if one thing
everyone learned through corona is like
you need more than one source of income
like i think that is kind of important
and to kind of have that set up the
property is full yeah so the the clap
and one is full
did you feel it yourself yeah was it
easy it it was crazily easy like the
people were literally lining up for the
proper people you make it look too easy
why would a landlord wanna what do you
have to say it to be fair it was a lot
easier than i thought like a lot easier
i literally just put it on spare room
did group viewing so then people got the
pressure of like this room is going to
go so the previous rent to rent managers
they dropped everyone's rent because of
covered and just to support so actually
when i took the property over initially
i thought one tenant was moving out but
it ended up being three tenants that
were moving out and at first i was i was
stressed about it because i was thinking
oh no i can't find tenants london rents
are quite expensive considering like
your salary and stuff so already i was
just like i hate paying so much rent
every month so then to know you've
signed two properties
that are way more rent than you're even
paying for the place that you're living
it was a little bit daunting so but then
so obviously the the three tenants were
moving out and i was thinking you know i
need to be able to afford the next
month's rent
um
so i started obviously advertising on
spare room and stuff and honestly i got
it filled so quickly with good tenants
past the references young professionals
clap on property you're making you're
talking about 800 a month so it's making
750 now so what i'm saying is i boosted
the the rent so it's making 750 now but
when the last tenant kind of moves out
or moves on i think it's around april
time it'll be 8.50 because i can push
that rent up so so so once that's sorted
it'll be 850 a month clean profit yeah
talk to me about the winter property
service accommodation how full has that
been what's been going on with that the
windsor property's been incredible to be
honest um
you know i was worried because it is a
whole different strategy to the hmo so i
was thinking you know
how is this going to be a hotel you know
it could dip in and out void periods i
remember when we met sorry but i
remember when we met with alex and we
sat down and alex was saying
you should be making 1 500 with this
property i was saying the grand he was
saying 1500.
and at the time i'm gonna have to be
real
i didn't sense that you actually
believed that that would be the case you
were literally asking to see my access
you were tell me what happened yeah so i
was at an event i think i was actually
asking evans to see his um because he
obviously has uh essays in the the same
street and obviously people are always
like oh yeah i'm making this amount i'm
making this amount i'm like i want
evidence like i want to see your account
you will and normally if i say to you
like oh i'll make oh my occupancy rate
is 96 in this area you'll just go i'm
interested now you're like i need to see
the proof yeah because you're putting
money on the line and and and you know
so i sense that you weren't too sure but
how how full has the service combination
been it's been amazing like it's been
full honest i would honestly say 95 of
the time like there's been a few like
issues like the boiler and then the
landlords fixed it straight away but
other than that well you can't have
someone in yeah i can't have someone in
but other than that it's it's been full
that's incredible what i do is i just
i'm just really on it like i'll monitor
it so say for example this um
this week like monday tuesday wednesday
wasn't full so i just dropped the prices
a little bit and then somebody booked it
that's the thing though i think service
accommodation and rental generally it is
a business
it's not something that's just
completely passive where you can say you
know and that's why
people sometimes get upset like you're
not really financially free because this
means it like but it's like well hang on
a minute the definition of financially
free firstly it's a little bit
subjective um my definition of financial
free is when your recurring property
income covers your living expenses
but rent to rent
i guess you can systemize it and you can
get managers but certainly in the early
days it is it does take a little not
loads of work but it does take a little
bit of um you know overseeing like you
say nudge the prices oh it's a bit empty
there let me drop the price here oh let
me just up the price here because
there's an event going on it just take a
little bit of looking at how much time
do you reckon you spend managing all of
your properties that you've got now on
average per week how much time would you
say you spent on it um i'd say i've
literally just got to the section where
it's like systemized now so
like literally not much at all like with
the essay two hours a week like
literally not just when i'm monitoring
it or getting in touch with the cleaners
the thing is though those two hours a
week
although that's pretty much passive yeah
yeah but
if you neglected those jobs a week if
you just did nothing the business would
prop slowly start becoming less and less
profitable so i think it is important
that people do realize that when you get
a property in the early days it's
different if you've got staff and you've
really systemized it but like i spend
like five minutes a month managing my
property portfolio i just don't not on
the property business but managing the
existing properties but it's like
you do need to put a bit of effort and
you do need to put a bit of work in you
can't just go now i'm going to line the
beach forever yeah of course yeah
definitely i think um
i think yeah the definition of financial
freedom that i feel from this is just
that i've got that set up like my living
expenses now you know if for whatever
reason i didn't have my job or you know
i'm sorted kind of thing everything's
all good and i only have to spend
literally a few hours a week managing it
so for me that's financial freedom
because i'm free of the stress i'm free
of i'm just free you know i can do what
i like i've got more choices yes that's
amazing and i'm so glad to see that for
you so the deals all went through you've
also as well i know i had a little
conversation a cheeky conversation in
the uh in the boardroom you've got a
potential joint venture partner as well
yes grow your slow pound yes um what was
it like working with me because you were
astonished that i had like business
meetings in my dressing room and stuff
yeah i was just a bit like
like this is the side that i've not seen
like i remember when we were in i was
talking to jl on the phone and you just
came in in your dressing gown and i was
just like okay the thing is i live and
breathe business and work so i'll wake
up in the there's nothing wrong with
eating cornflakes in your dressing camp
but i'm just happening to be doing
business meetings at the same time so
you know but it's been it's been great
working together what are your plans for
the future that now you're in a position
where you are financially free um you
you you're still
in the company for me
i'm always rooting for my staff in the
same way that i'm rooting for my eye i
don't think my i must i don't see my
staff as family i don't think
our business is like a family i think
it's we're a team and there's a big
difference between family and team i
think you know family members put up
with each other even when they're even
when they're
rubbish or difficult or idiots or you
just like what their family what can i
say teams if you're in a football team
and you've got a weak member of the team
you have to let them go yeah and i think
in a business i think we're a team
you're a great member of the team you're
financially free people probably don't
realize because a lot of people ask me
something if you make so much money and
you train in your property business why
do you have a training business um but
for me and you probably know this as
someone who spent a lot of time it's
mission it's fun it's fulfillment lying
on a beach forever and ever and ever
isn't actually that much fun
and hopefully you're now able to
experience the idea of i don't have to
do this this or this but i want to do it
from a position of abundance and fun and
hopefully we'll get more out of here
then you know but but if not that's fine
and i'm rooting for you i'm rooting for
everybody but what are your plans what
your plans over the next six twelve
months yeah so for me now it
it's weird because you do think you do
feel like um there's this now pressure
like i
i really want to kill it and i want to
show people that i can do this without
having my boss stood next to me and
helping me negotiate so i think for me
going forward and my house is hopefully
going through in january or february
which you'll buy yourself yes which i'm
buying myself which will be amazing um
but one thing i was going to say is the
mortgage initially obviously we thought
it was going to be 95
the mortgage broker was like it's going
to be 95 and when it actually came
through it was 90 percent so obviously
that's a bit it could be a massive worry
for me because you know that's doubling
how much money i have to have to put
down and so right now i'm just looking
to kind of deal source and and to
basically fund then i remember when you
rang me about that though and you were
like i don't think i'd have to go ahead
with the deal yeah and i was like of
course you are yeah 90 mortgage is still
crazy hard yeah because i was just
thinking how am i going to get the money
you know i know you'd have to pay it now
but you have to pay in you know three
months time where am i going to get the
money from but now i understand that
i'm a valuable person and i can give
value to the people by finding deals and
then obviously charging at charging a
fee for that as i always say rather than
saying i can't do this deal or i haven't
got the money it's okay how can i do the
deal how can i get the money i'm glad
that you've been able to do this for you
for your family but also so thankful to
my family like that that is one thing
that i wanted to say like your mom's a
rock star oh my like both my mum and my
dad like i just can't explain how
amazing they are like even obviously i
started this from my mum putting like it
down on credit cards like we didn't have
the money for it even like being on
camera like she hates being on camera
and she did that for me and like
supported me and looked for the property
and i just honestly i feel so grateful
and even to my dad like my dad's just
amazing like he's so proud of me like he
keeps just ringing me every like few
days like how's it going oh i've not met
your dad yet but i'm sure i mean but
your mom's your mom's a rock star your
mum's doing her own amazing things
knowing property as well which is great
i'm sure she'll be on windows wednesday
again soon
final words of wisdom to anybody
watching this that wants to do the same
thing too that wants to be successful
what would you say yeah i think i think
i would just say is
i think it sounds so cringy but it is
get down to the crash because like
that's where it all started for me
that's where it all starts for a
majority of the winners just come and be
around the environment and and don't be
scared to be a beginner like that's one
thing i really think because i think a
lot of people don't come down because
they're like
they're scared to put themselves out
there they're scared to be in a room
with people in property because they
think oh i'll be the only person that's
not doing things when most people that
come down to the crash course have never
done any deals have never you know so i
think just just take action educate
yourself watch the youtube channel come
down to the crash course well well done
what a pleasure i'm super proud of you
yeah yeah i'm honestly
words can't even explain how like i just
feel so thankful and grateful towards
you and the company for allowing me this
opportunity and even the opportunity to
be with the company for so long i think
i'm one of the longest standing members
of staff which obviously amazing um so
yeah i just honestly want to say i'm i'm
so so so so bad well done you killed it
well done so guys you heard it here
first if you want to do what amelia did
and you want to come down to training
and learn about property investment from
myself personally guess what tickets on
the house i'm going to leave a link in
the description if you haven't seen
amelia's financial freedom challenge the
financial freedom challenge movie maybe
you've been living under a rock for the
last week you can check it out right up
here if you want to see hundreds more
interviews like this with people that
i've helped become financially free
check out the entire playlist here
subscribe and we'll see you next time